i remember when i was a kid one of the
things that i hated was the fact that
anything could give me a [ __ ] boner
the no reason boners the nrb's dude
i [ __ ] hate our bees
to the moon so when i was uh younger my
parents would have me go to the store
right so and i'm younger and there'd be
some
david says some lascivious women that
would walk by now what kind of women
is lascivious that's latin pacific no i
think it means like
in five four three
two one welcome everybody
to another episode of the genius brain
podcast we have a very very special
guest here that you always see
we have patrick dot t dot crybaby riley
should have never told me you cried over
somebody you only saw fight twice
bro how are you gonna act like he's not
adorable he really is these are my legos
these are my legs
these are my my funko pops rosa when's
the last time you cried
uh on a plane watching i am sam
i am sam [ __ ] you up bro you haven't
seen imc's
that's the movie with uh sean penn sean
penn and that's where they said in
tropic thunder
don't go full [ __ ] yes it is
referencing
uh sean penn but he shows that he is so
good bro so good he's such a good actor
he's
who's [ __ ] and the champion
he sells it is is not what i said i read
this quote
on an imdb review he says he out
[ __ ] the retards in the film
i did not say that well that's good
acting but though
very true and very fair that's how
convincing it was
[ __ ] the retards yes also caught el
chapo
what a [ __ ] life this guy's lived huh
wait he well he did what oh
the reason el chapo got caught the drug
pin the cartel drug pin
was it was like an episode of south park
he for some reason
so el chapo is notorious [ __ ] number
one cartel due to mexico blah blah blah
for some reason invites sean penn to go
interview him
like so sean penn goes to interview him
for some reason it's sean penn
they go to the middle of the jungle in
mexico with this female mexican actress
who's
pretty [ __ ] bomb of course what are
they not they're [ __ ] new
news anchors are fine as [ __ ] too so
fine and so they go
interview them they they do they like
take a picture posing it's sean penn and
they'll chop up that
shirt that's the shirt that connor wears
yes that's where it's from right now
they're like shaking hands yeah like
this is a famous picture
and then they like a few weeks later
they catch all chopper they like tracked
him
through sean pennsylvania they were like
wait this somehow
shot it got known that the government
probably got a hold of the fact that
sean penn
was gonna go [ __ ] visit uh el chapo
and they're like okay well we're just
gonna like track you and they track them
and then el chapo god bless you it was
that easy
how was sean penn why would you invite
sean
he just really liked him as an actor and
he i bet he liked like the the female
guy he wanted to [ __ ] that girl
you [ __ ] out [ __ ]
what did you say earlier
once again just to save my eyes i did
not say that it was written
on the internet it was written we're
just reading it verbatim
but whatever was sean penn not dead bro
that's what i was thinking i was like
how does he
kill him how is his head not like on a
spear somewhere because the cartel
respects
good acting and they're like he's
[ __ ] untouchable you guys touch him
you're gonna have a problem have you
seen sam have you seen that david cried
and so did i
i'm not killing this [ __ ] you
better i bet i'll chop a crowd in that
movie
when was this how long ago was this when
you cried so i told this story with
jason cheney is when i
had this nervous breakdown because i was
in first class on the plane
and uh i fell asleep i guess right yeah
well i
got it by luck it wasn't good i deserved
it
so i got on the plane and long story
short everybody knows a story now
[ __ ] most embarrassing moment i
[ __ ] life
i got really drunk right but what
happened was i basically fell asleep
while they're passing out these ipads so
in first class hawaiian era they give
you ipads
and i i fell asleep and i didn't get an
ipad
but i didn't want them to know that i
didn't get an ipad okay sounds really
stupid as i say the story
but is this because i wanted them to
know that i belonged in [ __ ] first
class okay
so i chose not to get an ipad as well
you know what i'm saying yeah you're
like oh yeah it's whatever
it's okay i i always get the ipad today
don't worry i don't want it i don't want
it
because i didn't know that i didn't
belong in first class so i had this
dying phone and i was watching i
am sam but i got so smashed i
cried too much a lot like loud crying
whoa like like [ __ ] like that you
sounded like sam and i am saying yes i
did
okay
earphones on like earbuds so i didn't
know that i i was crying so loud until
my [ __ ] earbuds ran out of batteries
and i heard myself cry and then i looked
at the guy right to the right of me and
he's just mortified
he goes oh you were saying that somebody
the whole time
bro literally one of the worst
experiences of my life oh my god and i'm
[ __ ] asian
and i have boogers coming out of my face
and this dude is just
literally in a seat like this away from
me and i got so [ __ ] mine is well
face
in business you know probably suicide
like take the plane over or some [ __ ]
yep and i was too embarrassed to ask for
tissues so i just wiped the [ __ ] on my
sleeve
it was literally one of the worst
experiences this guy rides first class
that's right this guy is i got it by
chance
you watched i am sam i guarantee you if
you cried about moreno you're gonna
die i probably i honestly i like i get
choked up a lot in movies
because you have a daughter and this is
about a daughter oh for sure
for sure but even like in like goodwill
hunting when he's like it's not your
fault
oh hey he's like what do you mean what
the [ __ ] hey
hey it's not your fault i know i and
it's not my fault
for the [ __ ] it's not your fault
bro me right there like dude
shut the [ __ ] up yeah stop telling me
it's not my [ __ ] fault
[ __ ] yeah and i'm like oh my bad yeah
you are a [ __ ] dude yeah you crying
movies like that
they yeah i get choked up i do get
choked up i try not to but i do get
choked up it's stupid [ __ ] too like
stupid like what i don't know why
i don't know like even like i don't know
it depends on the movie or whatever but
do you feel like you're sentimental
yeah kind of he said that he has it so
aggressive i know
you said a metal are you saying bro
[Music]
and he's jacking off what do you do what
are you saying i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry and i just let him do it
and then you quit your comedy career
dude whatever
and then i go on facebook and i [ __ ]
cancel them yeah you can see all over
again
you think he's still jacking off on
people oh for sure on people probably
but like consider people like consenting
consent
i bet you there's like more way he's
learned now it's probably like with
someone he's very comfortable
or no or this everybody knows louis c.k
is the guy that likes to be watched
while he's jacking it so everyone's like
hey i'll watch you and you go
you could jerk off in front of tiff no
you couldn't no she would call the cops
on you well that's [ __ ] probably
you're like what are you doing
if i started dog imagine okay okay
i'll say this when you jack off
afterwards do you feel a little bit of
shame
at all yeah a lot
so imagine somebody's standing there
watching you jack off bro
you guys feel shame sometimes
but like you know the act of jacking off
is
bro this is what you think if somebody
saw me jack off right now
you'd you'd want to jump off a bridge
it's probably it's just
it's never it's never your best moment
but the thing is for me i feel if it's
like a really like well-deserved like
well needed like all right i needed to
do this
right like this is for like mental
health i don't feel shame at all i'm
like that was that was like
mental health that was like clear what
do they call it like taking a day for
self-care
yeah it's called self-care but like when
it's like just an indulging like eating
too much chocolate kind of
thing jerk off you know what i'm talking
where it's just too much because you're
bored
yeah it's like i could i could have been
doing something productive how long does
it take you to jack off though bro
it sounds like it's taking a big chunk
out of your day how much longer does it
take to fall okay this is a real
question
and i i'm pretty sure ladies don't even
ask about this yeah how long does it
take for you to not
from beginning to end when you jack off
it depends when you're in practice
and you're in rhythm bro and you've been
you're hitting on a regimen
actually i don't have no idea no i have
no concept of time when i'm jacking off
actually give us a guesstimation you
[ __ ]
time is an illusion dude hey time is an
illusion bro
time is a construct
yeah how about you how long does it take
you to bust a knife least 35 seconds to
maybe two minutes depending on what i'm
thinking about
wow right if i haven't jacked off in a
very long time or haven't had sex in a
long time
it's pretty [ __ ] easy i don't know
but
here's the thing is like it's it i see
what you're saying
but like it feels better if you prolong
it
oh i'm just doing it as a task so i can
start getting to work again yeah you do
it yeah
you clear it that's the thing is like i
take my time
no wonder you're crying you like
the way he was talking about jacking off
was like it was a whole thing
[Music]
it's not a production i just i okay this
way you don't feel yourself we check out
this one
i have a process i go like this i go i
look first of all i look at the new like
what's up what's going on out there
right that's popular right
the front pages boom boom boom i like
these
five for four videos right you narrow it
down i i narrow it down
i go okay this one looks cool it's cool
but then you need like you can't jump
right in like when you see porn like but
there's like the really good ones like
the the ones where you're like damn i
really want to see what's going on in
this video
but then there's others like you don't
you you always eat an appetizer before
you get to that you know
my man yo hold on a second my man said
he needed a move
he said yo give me my mousse boosh and
appetizer my three course meal yeah bro
jump straight into the the main entree
right off the bat you got to like kind
of get talk about it get it going you
got to like get the little
like you got to start like you got to
break it down you got it a little
sensitive and then you jump into the big
one
into the good one and then but then
there's four good ones so then you're
like which one is the finisher
because i want to see all these eclipses
when do you go to work
it sounds like a solid time like two
hours it sounds like you're it sounds
like you're
producing a beat and you're like all
right
you're releasing like samples you're
like this would be good on the hook
actually
actually let me take that i'll take it
away this is the vocal drop we're gonna
do at the beginning of the song
like that's what it sounds like you're
piecing everything i'm just like hey i
don't play games
when your boy gets his nut he gets his
nut bro but see that's my problem if i'm
doing this too much it does take two
like i'm like this
i gotta do give us the time bro he's
been holding his daughter had lunch
or breakfast or dinner breakfast she's
just sitting in there
please she's like daddy's collaging i
mean
time daddy's [ __ ] scrapbook
masturbating right now
[Laughter]
this mother's like a scrapbook
masturbating bro that's what it's called
dude
oh my god oh [ __ ]
bro he's
i'm a somalian pirate you should have a
service where you're like hey man i want
to know the perfect video to nut from
and you're like all right and then you
acquire all these
different videos that fits this person's
needs
honestly sure there's a market really
honestly that's a great idea i never
thought it was actually a market for
that i'm sure there is but even like
when you're having sex too it's like it
feels better if you just kind of like
hold off like hold off to you just
really can't
yeah but that's sex though this is just
masturbation
so i can start getting [ __ ] done i jack
off so fast also because
i don't i want to beat the reality
that i'm touching my own dick yeah so
okay i'm trying to get rid of that
reality as fast as possible i'm more of
davis camp
i i'm i'm there to just to get it done
and move on but
i do respect the self-care i do respect
it's like self-care i do respect the
fact that you break
out of your way and you're like hey man
this is just the process baby
this is just the way when i do this
super quick nut like just to get it out
of the way because i'm like that too
where i'm like i feel like i i want to
do something but i'm too distracted i'm
like i just got to get this out of the
way
but when i when i jerk off quick like
that then i'm like [ __ ] i could that
could have been way
better and then it makes me mad that i
wasted that that
wasted that night you have us you you're
sentimental with your nuts
i mean i guess i feel something you
don't like so no
this is all making sense remember that
time this will came to the podcast two
hours late he was jacketed
was jacking off bro you just got
caught bro this full set i got a triple
a i gotta go
why the triple he doesn't have a triple
a card bro
show us the triple a card right see what
club member you got bro i don't got one
[Laughter]
yo you lying son of a [ __ ] this one had
a triple nut is what he did dude
i hope that nut was worth it bro it was
that is crazy i had no idea you were so
meticulous with it well it's just it's
just he was locked in his own car
you know what it is it's it's a it's a
craft and uh it's just taking years
yeah not everybody could be jedi's bro
we're not generally i don't know it's
just that's how
but that's the thing is like when i when
i i have to if i'm doing it like a
well-deserved one i'm like oh this is
cool if i have the time like say i have
a long time
but like if it's like a like i i'm
it's just too much like if i have to
rush it then i'm like why the [ __ ] am i
even wasting my time
and then two if i'm doing it too much
it's like damn i'm like this is taking
too much time
constitutes as a well-deserved nut yeah
that's a really good question
like been working a lot like haven't had
anything like having had a day off
it's been a while since you got that nut
it been a while it's been a while it's a
while though
calendar year no no a couple weeks it
depends like a week and a half
i try to push it like yeah like a week
and a half
that's i think that's something you do
for yourself a weekly basis i'm so
shocked dude i never knew that there was
somebody out there that cares that much
about the masturbation
i don't it's not that i care it's just
that it's like it feels
so much better when i do it like that
it's like if i can nut and feel like
like step like the quick nut it feels
good but it's like uh yeah that was nice
or it could be like damn it could feel
like that or you're like i bet
i bet this was more common with ladies i
bet i bet how
like girls get through that i bet that's
more common with them when i wonder if a
bunch of girls are like yeah pat you're
right that's that
i don't write you know what i don't
think i don't think well maybe maybe it
is but i just know
i've cause i've talked to girls about it
and especially girls that use vibrators
like for them it's like
usually pretty like and then it's like
over but there's probably some girls
that are like
that like that they like that they like
the curation of the videos that they
watch
yeah i remember when i was a kid one of
the things that i hated was the fact
that
anything could give me a [ __ ] boner
the no reason boners the nrb's dude i
[ __ ] peace
i [ __ ] hate
so when i was uh younger my parents
would have me go to the store
right so and i'm younger and there'd be
some
davis some lascivious women that would
walk by now what kind of women
is lascivious that's latin the civ
i know i think it means like evil or
some [ __ ] like that little little loose
women
let's look at that that's like that is e
pluribus unum
yo they would come through be lascivious
sexual women walking
looking for hair pieces looking fine as
[ __ ] oh yeah you're right
dude and i'm [ __ ] like 13 or 14 right
there it says
sorry to cut you off feeling a revealing
and overt and often offensive
sexual desire sexual desire
i just remember i would have to like my
mom would be like watch the customers i
have to go to the bathroom real quick
it's only because your boy had a raging
boner and i just had to knock one out
before in the bathroom because i would
like jack off in my parents door and
just go right into the toilet
and then just do it as fast as possible
so i could concentrate on them to make
sure that they're not [ __ ] jacking
[ __ ] yeah that's why
but they were so [ __ ] see the way he
put his hand up on the wall yeah
it was just like this he was like [ __ ]
my mom's like what are you doing i was
like i gotta make sure i watch the
customers that's why
i have to do this yeah oh and they were
so fine some of the girls that won the
store man they were [ __ ] a-plus
it was banging it wasn't [ __ ] falling
i already had this one sticks out
oh this was probably when i was like 14
to like 17. yeah bro because you just
can't control them when you're younger
dude that was like the worst part is
when
when the dick wanted to go up it wanted
to happen and there is nothing that you
can do about it yeah
you can talk to it like hey don't
[ __ ] embarrass me he goes what'd you
say
and he just stands the [ __ ] up it looks
right in your eye i hated that [ __ ] dude
that's a problem that's a problem in
every
young man's life you know yeah
everywhere in a young man's life yep
everywhere
everywhere in all aspects of life you
know what i mean everywhere in a young
man's life
i still can't believe you're a scrapbook
masturbator dude yeah bro i'll never
move
in movies i scrap book masturbate now
the quiet
the fact that you came two hours late to
the podcast because you're jacking up
honestly it was david's fault because he
got into your scheduling and it was a
scheduling conference yeah you didn't
know i was i was like
i was not on you bro
[Music]
yo have you guys ever jacked off when
you were taking a hot shower and then
you almost passed out
i've definitely jacked off during the
hot shots but no never almost passed me
neither but that's crazy
that's crazy
i thought that was common knowledge but
apparently it's not okay so we're going
to
fly into the water bro why'd you almost
pass out yeah
it's steamy but i'm like damn you got
this never happened
not almost past that but it's i i'm
definitely hot [ __ ] showers
i'll say that before you explain
yourself yeah why what
i know david bro when he does something
he does it to the nth degree like he
takes it
over the top when he's training my boy
trains hard yo
almost too hard so when he beats his
meat in the shower
he's probably over exerting himself it
sounds like you need a stroke it sounds
like you drink more water before you
you shower i thought that was a common
thing that doesn't happen like when it's
super hot and [ __ ] you don't get
lightheaded
no damn man hey so this wraps up this
episode
i counted below it's only 20 minutes
how do you guys jag off dude you need to
get into scrapbook masturbating bro
that's what it sounds like this is dude
i got so much people on the asmr there
you go that's a whole new channel right
there oh dude
the sound of jacking off is weird no no
not that just like the whole scrap the
process
like hey guys welcome to my channel it
sounds like that boom i'm in a robe
you know what's the best though when
like what's up this is people
and you just keep you just keep you know
you just bring it's a whole
thing i feel like there's a market for
that oh you you'll be able to that was
for you bro that's your service that you
give out to other people just like uh
like a scrapbook
you give them a playlist of yeah there's
a playlist so it's the amuse
the appetizer the [ __ ] main course
the second course and then
yeah dude it could be like playboy after
like hugh hefner used to have this tv
channel like playboy after dark and he
would like
he'd come he'd come on a robe and like
you'd go up an elevator and like hey
it's time to hang out like frank sinatra
and some playboy bunnies
so it could be like that and then i
could just hook you up with a playlist
bang bang bang yeah yeah what do you
like
you doing well quiz at the beginning
yeah yeah yeah and then you'd be like oh
i could help this person and
i know exactly what i could show you
yeah and we just class up the joint a
little bit you know
gets a bad rap one of my favorite things
because i don't watch porn as much as i
used to
is when i like scrolling through
something real quick just to jack off
real fast
and then i'll see a porn video i i
forgot about completely
and it feels brand new all over again
yeah that is the best
yeah when you revisit it you're like oh
i'm like whoa i'm like a kid again i
didn't i couldn't remember the title or
the name
but look it's here and it came up yeah
wow christmas is here and i jacqueline
take her in 10 seconds synchronicity
baby
baby manifest destiny dogs
what do you watch i don't care like to
be honest with you
oh if i see a fine ass [ __ ] woman
walk by guess what i got what i need
i'm watching that it's just like i look
at her and she goes what are you looking
at
too late [ __ ] it's like that patricia
meal thing it's literally that [ __ ]
i'm so [ __ ] visual and [ __ ] i could
look at the finest woman ever and be
like
guess what [ __ ]
wow i go into the bathroom on my parents
store i drive all the way to sacramento
and i jack off in the same spot
at all yeah your boy just needs one
visual one imagination
i'm done that's kind of nice i'm locked
in the cabin and for some reason this
girl and i were locked in the cabin and
we have six hours before somebody can
save us
the only way that we can make it out is
if we get butt naked get into a [ __ ]
uh sleeping bag that we had to stitch
together with one zipper yeah
classic scenario yeah i love it the
classic scenario
either we [ __ ] or we died
i guess we're going to [ __ ] and it was
her idea not mine
yeah consensual and then you're
reluctant you're like i don't know i
don't know if i should do this because i
feel right yeah but yeah
it doesn't feel right i don't know i
can't i don't know i feel like we should
get married first
and then she's like no no david we have
to do this for our lives guess what
in this scenario mariel's already dead
yeah yeah yeah
obviously though you're very sad you're
very sad about it uh my girlfriend died
she's like hey but we need to [ __ ] you
the world's gonna end yeah and you're
like but this just struggled my
girlfriend to be like your girlfriend
would want you to do this
start sucking your dick with merrell's
ghostbuster weird
no she's actually floating and her arms
across he goes thank you
you have my blessing
dude meryl's so cool i miss you
she goes my job is done here
she goes david you must do this
the protagonist has to be a guy that
looks similar to david not exactly just
similar
yeah that's [ __ ] that is the best
inferno [ __ ] ever for justice and it
must be made by the
the the one porn company that does the
super cinematic [ __ ] dude
with the b-roll with the cool b-roll and
then like the the drone shots
yeah over the city the unnecessary drum
shots over the city yeah
that one's called a b-roll and the
soundtrack is we are the world
we uh what is that real quick
dude dude it's like the easiest thing to
make everyone should make it i think
that's a million dollar
that's that's bro that's amazing i don't
think porn directors make a lot of money
though do they
well part of it is like how do they make
money because doesn't everything end up
on the internet like
advertisement [ __ ] i bet you the ads
because like you still go like on
pornhub there's still ads you know so
he's just clicking on those [ __ ] ads
though bro there's some real creeps out
there
who goes to the conventions people go
pay tickets to go to these conventions
to be [ __ ] weirdos but my whole thing
is like who
what is the market there's like a new
supplement
that makes you come more like who's
buying this oh you're talking about
peter north he was he was um listen
peter north i don't know too many like
porn names but peter north was known
as the guy who was the og bro come on
ladies like
a [ __ ] he grew up watching that
dude yeah so there was no north
it was children two major porn stars at
the time was uh jenna jameson and peter
north and this is like
late early 90s and you know i think
jenna jameson now is
like a mogul she's like a porn star
mogul oh yeah like she capitalized on
the industry and she became a boss in
this [ __ ]
well peter north he remember people were
making jokes about this all the time
but he was selling pills that would like
multiply your [ __ ] load like a ridiculous
i'm not sure if it worked yeah how and
what but why do you want to yeah
for the real question is why why do you
want to come more
but i guess for some guy i'm sure
there's some guys that just come a
little bit and you think it's
embarrassing for them
that's just because they're jacking off
too much yeah yeah yeah let it chill for
a couple days
let the boys recount days yeah even a
day honestly it comes back like pretty
good
yeah a day a day
two days yeah you need to rest six days
and you'll get like a good amount you'll
get a lot six days you'll get a lot
you get
your milk is collecting breast milk and
then you just start squirting
yeah that's actually science guys that's
science i know science
common misconception people don't think
that's real it's a real phenomenon
um but yeah one who wants to come more
well
we solved that question but who does
this [ __ ] even work
like how does it even work there's just
a lot of weird like fetishes when i was
in uh what the psych minor
i there was this one specific part of
the course that we're taking which was
like uh like perversion and sex and some
[ __ ]
right but there's [ __ ] some [ __ ] called
what plush ophelia where people like to
dress up as dolls and teddy bears and
[ __ ] each other
there was this one weird one called pie
ophelia which
take a guess they get hard or [ __ ]
horny or
wet quit when you throw pies in each
other's faces and
that's the second i i thought it was
gonna be different i thought i was gonna
be american pie style
no no no you take a pot pie and you
throw it and they they did a study where
they asked them
what is the part that makes you like so
aroused it's the part where the pie
filling gets stuck in the hair that's
the [ __ ] that makes them horny
i have a question do you think people
like like this what the [ __ ]
yeah do you think people get into the
stuff because they realize it's a thing
like once you put a title on it do you
think it's
it's more likely for people to be like
oh [ __ ] like i'm into that
versus if there wasn't even a name or a
community at all like you think
people would still be doing this [ __ ] i
don't know many questions some [ __ ] that
[ __ ] turns people on is just
different dude like
shrimping which is where you suck on
toes that's what it's called that's what
it's called
shrimping did not know that yeah why
cause like the toes represent the shrimp
yes i guess it looks like the head of
the shrimp or some [ __ ] i don't know i'm
just saying
something this is literally i'm on board
these three things is what i remember
from college and that's all i remember
what do you think it's gonna be like for
kids growing up in this day and age
because you could access porn
whenever they get desensitized yeah but
you know about guys
who have uh porno addictions they watch
porn so much and i'm not talking about
every day i'm talking about
breakfast lunch dinner non-stop to the
point where their idea of sex becomes
porn
and they only can get sexually aroused
by these extremities like this extreme
[ __ ]
yeah so they don't have sex with their
partners very well they can't even get a
heart on when they [ __ ] an actual human
being
right and i say this because i know i
knew somebody that one for the first
time
yeah isn't it [ __ ] crazy it's weird i
didn't i didn't think
i didn't i never thought i would ever
meet someone with that issue
but like you know i could understand how
you know that stuff happens because i'm
sure it's a slippery slope
like you get you start watching all the
time and then it becomes your [ __ ]
norm and like that's how you deal with
things you know
but it is a crazy thing to think about
that like dude
i just had this random [ __ ] memory my
first girlfriend that i had i remember
because i used to watch porn right but
this girl was
very demure she was very elegant
wasn't into sexual perversion [ __ ] right
and you know i was a virgin at the time
but you know your boy was watching an
excessive amount of porn yeah yeah right
huh i mean when you're young like you're
trying to watch that [ __ ] every day yeah
non-stop all the [ __ ] time and that
[ __ ] was on the 56k modem so you know
that [ __ ] picture took a while to
come up
you were always like having a porn
download in the background yeah back in
the day like when you had
when you had yeah when you had limewire
and torrents like it would it would take
like three days
i never used kazakhstan because you're a
loser you have no
friends nobody loves you bang go
move on from this huh go loser guys i
don't want to talk about this
we would get one video and rewatch that
[ __ ] so much because it took [ __ ]
forever to get
porn wow that's just you guys are so
blessed and sometimes you would download
porn
and then you would play it and this
file's not supported by a computer
and you're trying to look up the plugins
what plugin do i need i need to get this
nut bro like yeah
you're trying to solve this problem but
you would never that [ __ ] that [ __ ] used
to piss me off
you guys remember the website milfunter
i do i loved it i never saw it
never saw it you never saw so there's
this guy he would go around just [ __ ]
everyone
he was the milf hunter he was the
military he would [ __ ] that was the
whole thing
no creativity i remember as a kid like
watching that [ __ ] and i'd be like
i'll be like there's no way he [ __ ] all
the time
and this is what i thought and i was
like what are the videos of him like
going up to these ladies and then
getting rejected like this is this is
[ __ ] like this guys and also too
i was like how does not people like more
people not know this guy like he's
[ __ ] everyone's mom
yeah yeah i just i just thought it was
real i thought it was i thought it was
real too before
and sometimes i would feel like bad i
was like yo someone's mom bro
like yo this is [ __ ] up honestly it
could have still been somebody's mom
it probably is in real life that's true
you never thought that that way yeah
thank you for
showing me that perspective there it is
that's real cool there's a company
[ __ ] i can't remember the name but i
this podcast is brought to you by fiverr
if you are looking for a network of
on-demand freelance talent look no
further
whether you're launching your first
business scaling your current business
or in need of
extra support from graphic design
copywriting marketing film editing
you name it you can find the best help
you need
on fiverr now i use fiverr whenever i
need a quick logo or graphic done fiverr
always has my back it's super easy to
contact freelance work and get precise
deadlines from reliable
help you don't need to do everything
yourself that's dumb stop wasting your
time trying to fill every role when you
can hire freelancers who can get it done
for you
while you focus on the stuff you need to
get done
it's super important and yes it's that
easy to get the help you need so check
out
fiverr.com and receive 10 off your first
order by using my code
geniusbrain find all the digital
services you need in one place
at f i v e r
code geniuspin again that's fiverr.com
code geniusbrain there was a couple of
guys who had this company
where they were doing the scenario where
it's a girl's first time doing porn ever
i don't know what the what the series is
called personality casting cow [ __ ] like
some [ __ ] like that but it's not casting
couch that's like the og one right
that's like from back in there when i
used to jack off frequently
but this one couch boy that black pouch
bang this guy
who used to create this stuff and it
wasn't just him it was a you know
whatever
the videographer the director and
whatever the company is like three or
four guys
but a couple of them went to jail
recently for like
20 years for what for i guess like
surprisingly
we're [ __ ] duping women into doing
porn like and forcing them to have sex
how how they would like they would i
don't know what they would do
i'm not i don't want to go ahead and
spread rumors but it was some i don't
think they were drugging them or
whatever right i will this is what i'll
do this is what i'll say this is what i
bet happens right
the girl goes there right and then she's
getting cold feet and then she kind of
doesn't want to do it mm-hmm
and then they just [ __ ] keep prodding
at them or whatever
i don't know almost to the point where
they kind of like force them to do that
[ __ ] yeah
and reluctantly obviously yeah but to
the point where they
i'm sure they do anything they can
because it's like okay
we gotta shoot these videos because like
at the end of the day like whether it's
as dark as it is
it's still like they still gotta shoot
this content they gotta get they gotta
get these videos out [ __ ]
so i'm sure also in their mind they're
just like yo let's we gotta get this we
gotta get dude
we gotta get this shot there was these
poor girls or the victims of it you know
there was this thing going around it's
the same type of series there's this
thing going on around on reddit it was
huge but it was this guy who was either
in the marines he's about to get
deployed
he's standing next to this really cute
girl
but there's a video of her getting
[ __ ]
it was that company oh that's the
company that was the company that got
sued wait so
this guy was getting deployed and the
girl ended up
that dude with was on this one just
getting piped and she was fine too she's
really cute and so it's like me and my
man blah blah blah and they're like
everybody's like yo i know that girl
that's like my favorite video
and this dude goes off into the milk
gets deployed like in like
afghanistan so like
that whole [ __ ] about when guys go to
the military and the girls just get
piped out by everyone that's like a real
thing
so fast they made a movie about that
[ __ ] with tobey mcguire oh yeah jarhead
yes is that what that's about no that's
jake gyllenhaal
who's toby mcguire spider-man i think
jake jones was in that movie they're
brothers
i remember they're a marine movie where
some lady sends a tape of her [ __ ]
some other dude to the guy
he's in iraq or whatever well i think
that works but i think uh this movie i'm
talking about like
he gets deployed his wife starts
sleeping with his brother or some [ __ ]
he's also a military guy and then they
they like i forgot how the movie ends
but
because because they have to pretty bad
already because they have to because the
brother
was killed in a war in a gun fight
in order to to [ __ ] heal their hurt
they
have to have sex right and then his
ghost comes in and they go i give you my
blessing
you gotta save the world every film that
be direct
it's with a ghost that goes i give you
my blessing
are these ghosts bro what's with this
[ __ ] ghostboard [ __ ] dude
it's boring it has nothing to do with it
at all it's like a [ __ ]
murder production david patnick
dude people will watch that should you
crazy oh yeah i really think they would
actually yeah you're right people watch
that [ __ ] i have to [ __ ] you i can't
forget my brother he died
well guess what we could be one just
enter this [ __ ]
how good is that [ __ ] [ __ ] perfect
[Music]
three weeks we're all in jail i know
but yeah they just made some dumb ass
porn overall they got arrested i think
they convicted the guy
who uh was in the porn so he's the guy
that's having sex with the girl
i think he's the first one to go to jail
oh [ __ ] i think it was like 20 years it
was a lot wow oh
[ __ ] so is so rape i guess it has to be
raped these [ __ ] scumbags dude
they're scum bags because like
like some rapists they just be getting
out bro what was that about
but they they also did a video with it
was a huge scandal and
we did this on jk news um and this is
why i saw some of the videos was because
miss delaware was on there
she was like miss t miss universe or
some [ __ ] yeah she was miss delaware she
won that [ __ ]
and then um she was supposed to either
go to miss universe or whatever
uh watch the jk news episode but they
found out because of the porn and she
she vehemently denied it wasn't her but
clearly it's you
she's like it's me miss delaware i'm
getting piped
yeah she's just like yeah i kind of
needed the money or some [ __ ] like that
and then she just gets
[ __ ] wrecked like piped down but that
company gained a lot
of fame because of that video because
delaware was on there and it was a huge
story
yeah but they found out that they're
[ __ ] scumbags because in our mind we
know
that this is supposed to be fake and set
up like these are like clearly their
porn stars
yeah but people kind of play with the
imagination that they're not so it's a
turn on or whatever
yeah but everybody's assuming or if
you're smart enough that there are porn
stars but they're not these girls got
dupe these guys are [ __ ] trash bags
yeah because it's there is a whole genre
of like making them seem random right
but at the same time it's like you never
see them in other pornos right
like these girls yeah i'm assuming i'm
assuming they usually do one-offs right
like well because like when you
sometimes when you watch porn like i
remember
it'll be like my first time and i'm 18
and they clearly look like they're 36
and destroyed
yeah right yeah they do better yeah come
on yeah
you came in the [ __ ] scene with a [ __ ]
stain on the back of your head what are
we doing here for the second shoot of
the day yeah yeah yeah so
i've seen you in other [ __ ] in our mind
we're thinking everything is consensual
but these [ __ ] scumbags were like
coercing these girls to have sex
oh wow yeah i'm sure that happens a lot
though right you know one of the biggest
reasons why i actually like reduced the
amount of porn that i'm watching sex
trafficking
well i watched this uh this doc on sex
trafficking
and it was the saddest [ __ ] thing if
i showed you guys you would probably you
would reduce your porn amount by like 90
i don't really watch porn ba lies i
swear i don't know hey people who say
that watch the sickest point ever
bangs uh horses and ladies
oh yeah yeah yeah what's the thing
called look at him fake stutter we saw
the real stutter here yeah
yeah yeah no i don't really watch porn
anymore bro yeah it's not as i mean
definitely so i watched this dock where
this um this guy went to asia i forgot
whether it was thailand or china or
whatever it was right but it was the
saddest [ __ ] thing because he's
trying to save these young girls who are
being sex trafficked
and he has like a hidden camera you see
it all in the night of dark
it was like a dock series but this guy
he goes into whatever get his dicks up
quote-unquote really he's just trying to
save these girls
and these girls just interview him with
[ __ ] he's got his dick sucked first and
then he's like
he's like all right time to save you i
gotta help you out i guess there it is
but this girl like this young girl is in
there and he's fine she's trying to
undress him and he's
like he's crying he's crying because
he's just like he's seeing all this
crazy yeah she's like do you she's
she's basically asking like either it's
been a while but
it's been a while but he was asking like
she was asking him if she wants to like
suck his dick or whatever and he's just
like
crying his eyes are bawling because he
has a daughter
and he sees this [ __ ] and he's like
trying to like save this girl and after
that i was like
porn reduced by like 90 that's why i
stopped watching porn is because i have
a daughter bro
you're supposed to look this way oh yeah
yeah i have a daughter bro
yeah i don't know i have a daughter but
but this one goes back to a scrapbook
goes home burns it he goes i can't do
this anymore right before he puts in the
fire he stops he's like no
but i can't it's like the lord of rings
when he's gonna burn the ring
and he's like make me good
you're just in the lava still holding
the ring smiling
yeah i mean that sucks that i mean
that's the thing about that but if you
really start to
if you stop and think about what porn is
and like how damaged a lot of these
girls are
and the sex trafficking element of it
that goes into it it's like
yeah it's fouls [ __ ] yeah that that dock
kind of wrecked me for a little bit man
yeah i don't know it doesn't have to do
with like porn stars because obviously
like porn stars they're in it for the
money they have right history it's a
different market
it's a different market but just so for
some reason that that jumbled in my head
and it just reduced well because there
is a seedy side of like
business it's grimy [ __ ] and also too
like a lot of women that are in porn
are have been sexually abused yeah some
sexually traumatic things that have
happened to them
i told you just like you're jerking off
like damn she probably got raped when
she was five and you're like oh [ __ ]
yeah you can't get that
i told you guys about the the porn stars
that i had on this podcast that tried to
[ __ ] blackmail me
oh so i i had i had a guest on this
podcast right
and the reason why i invited her to this
podcast is because she was an
agent oh yeah yeah and i remember tried
to [ __ ] blackmail me and her
backstory when she was she was
i don't know if it's true or not but it
was pretty [ __ ] nuts
and this girl was trying to me too my
ass i was like girl
you don't even know you're barking up
the wrong tree i'm asexual as [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's crazy dude you crazy he's nuts
dude i [ __ ] jack off in the shower
and pass out
you're like i already got this i don't
need to hang out with you yeah
i saw you from a distance easy
she didn't know that right when we
started i was like i need to use the
restroom
you got the one on the training at the
beginning of the podcast oh my word
so how was that podcast was that a good
podcast was terrible i ended it early
because she was going off on tangents
she was saying crazy [ __ ] that it got
really [ __ ] uncomfortable
and the type of questions that i was
asking her was so [ __ ] basic it was
like hey
as an asian american like we we both
know what it feels like to be you know
under scrutiny of our parents it's like
it's crazy that you actually got into
the adult industry
and you have a relationship with your
mother or father and that's what these
were the things i was asking it's like
so
how do your parents deal with it how did
you get in this and then she started
messaging
like joe and all these other people
saying like well how do you feel about
your
your uh co-workers well actually she'd
even say that she called
me his employee highly offensive
um uh [ __ ] uh forcing women to answer
uncomfortable questions i was like
forcing because you had a gun ahead of
you i was like four you
choked on a dick yesterday i asked you
how do your parents feel about you being
in this industry and how did you get
it to be fair she wasn't choking at all
it was actually quite impressive so
watch your [ __ ] mouth
oh my bad watch your [ __ ] face like a
[ __ ] champion okay
i've never seen a single video of her in
porn ever i just know
that she's in the adult industry because
i got a message from my friend who's a
big fan of her didn't she hit you up
she was on a sentence no no we got to
cut that out
[Laughter]
no the only reason why is because i
don't want to feel this girl's wrath
yeah right because she's crazy dude i'm
talking about
so a buddy of mine started finding she's
going to find this wrong [ __ ]
she'll find you dude hey [ __ ] he's going
to deep dive in finding out about who
she is because i was telling him like yo
i'm freaking out but then i was like
hold on a second it was in an
office building there's cameras
everywhere if i need to get the footage
i had the recorded footage and the audio
the show i didn't do anything
and i sent her an uber home right when
the podcast ended your boy is
[ __ ] good though yeah yeah and so i
was like okay
he starts doing a deep dive on she's
like on twitch
doing anything for money non-sexual like
somebody will write in the comments
jumping jacks no [ __ ] like that it'll be
like get three eggs and crack it over
your face and she goes
okay he cracks three eggs on her head
you can make money doing that
yay wow you could make money doing
anything
i got some eggs at the house and only
fans right now
like yeah i'm cool bro that's how i feel
yeah you're such a [ __ ] loser man
i hate you so much i'm working on it
though it's a process
i'm learning and i'm working on it nice
what [ __ ] i start crying yeah [ __ ]
all you do is stutter and be a loser
all day that is kind of my mri i do be
stuttering i'd watch your only fans
honestly i would right
what would you do like that i would
laugh nothing i wouldn't do it
with sailor moon and then not do it i
wouldn't do it probably that's that's
kind of my you're [ __ ] dumb dude i
just like i don't like this [ __ ]
and i just won't do it you know what i
don't even post stories on my instagram
bro like you know what the crazy thing
is
before this podcast started i had a very
clear objective and i forgot what we
were going to talk about
we're going to talk about remember
that story was very good though it was
patrick
you know i appreciate patrick for
sharing that with us something very
intimate
that he does in his alone time with all
the genius brain listeners at home i
appreciate that
friendship forever disgusting pig
yeah i did yeah don't judge bro okay i
want to know about you passing out in
the shower with
hot showers and beating off i thought
that that's what happens to everybody
you're in there like and you're like you
got to catch up sit down hold on you got
to sit down have you asked
huh who have you asked about this i
didn't ask anybody
i just assumed that's normal do you sit
down to prepare yourself for the fall or
no so like it happened once when i was
in high school
did you did you pass out or you caught
yourself like whoa like i was jacking
off in the shower and i take very hot
showers
and then i was on my tippy toes i was
trying to nut real fast hey i feel that
hey you know what it is
yeah i told the story on here before
yeah i got a cramp one time and i
actually like pulled a muscle in my calf
you pulled a muscle yeah i'm jerking off
yeah my when i was like i was like in uh
i was in eighth grade beating his meat
god damn
how hard were you jerking off you pulled
a [ __ ] muscle hey bro my calves
weren't very
like they weren't very strong
jesus yeah uh and then my dad like saw
me limping around the house and he just
like just very quietly and stoically
just said
nick you gotta you gotta stop
masturbating so much i'm like what dad
what are you talking about
i just ran back in my room how did he
gather that from you just having to hurt
lazy done it multiple times he goes
that's a done genetic trait
it's called the masturbation calf cramp
the duns have weak calves you jerked off
so hard you injured yourself
legitimately it sounds like you don't
jerk off hard enough i guess so i guess
maybe hey maybe you didn't step up your
game bro what's going on
i pictured with his dad he brings out
this old dusty book
of just like all the times he goes this
has been in our family for years
and he opens it up it's just the calf
cramp diagram
family three achilles heel right here
oh you're dragging off in the shower
your grandfather's like oh
it's like a drawing of somebody
grandfather methuselah
[Laughter]
your boy was still beating his meat
although i can't believe you
you cast your crap that's what i was
about to say yeah yeah yeah yeah
your calf so and to the point where you
pulled a muscle
yeah bro it's a lifestyle dog it's not
for everybody
you were sitting down or standing up dog
who sits down in the shower and
beats oh you were in the shower so you
were you were like you were like
i was trying to get this you ever seen
michael jackson go up like completely
like you were
like you were like you were like past
that you had to go past that point
i was on like the front side of my
ankles my ankles were bending backwards
i was like gumby dude yeah i saw michael
jackson do that but like that's
humanly impossible no one could go past
this point but you actually actually did
it
and paid the price yeah you see michael
jackson where he goes over his toes like
this
like this yeah yeah his heels on the
ground yeah i'd be doing that too and he
stopped himself with his dick he's on
the wall
and then he came in that night
to the beat
hey that should be a fun game yeah put
on a song
put on a song and then just you know go
to the strokes and the reason you're a
loser
how about that yeah okay but we're
talking about your [ __ ] porn collage
man this guy just talked about collagen
i'm just trying to add to it self-care
[ __ ]
trying to make this a game 2021 yeah
cause he's [ __ ] bro you don't
you don't it's because before you work
out do you stretch four months
i treat myself it's a tree to do some
jumping jacks and [ __ ] everybody passes
out when they jack off and take a hot
shower
everybody this is right in the comments
if you're watching this on youtube
how many of you guys passed out
everyone's about david's got bungee
cords in the [ __ ] showers and he
passes out he's like
oh he's looking like pinocchio
i'm just saying i'm hanging like this
when david passes out a siren goes off
in the house and she's like oh [ __ ]
she has to go in the bathroom she knows
the routine again
dick's still coming yeah but we'll at
least get into the topic i [ __ ]
forgot
it still it's coming it's everywhere i'm
coming bro
she's like oh god david oh it smells
like bleach and [ __ ]
[ __ ] so guys if you guys don't know gary
owens
very famous comic that's crazy that was
literally 50 minutes of masturbation
time
but [ __ ] the craziest podcast
i've ever done in my life dude this is
this is what the people want to hear
this is this is the normal man's stuff
people need to hear it yeah maybe it's
in us it's
it's got my female subscribers
but gary owens recently during movies
sorry go ahead recently got divorced
and she he came on to the wendy owens
show do you think he has a masturbation
problem is that what well 100 he does
dude
i'm pretty sure he he's so pale and
white that when he masturbate he just
turns cherry red
100 dude yeah he's passing out in the
shower with me and we're both dead
hey gary owens hit me up let's jack off
together so
he goes on the wendy williams show and
in the most uncomfortable thing i've
ever seen
williams is literally shooting her
[ __ ]
shot at him over and over and over damn
like relax [ __ ] super [ __ ] easy
people talking about the first time she
ever saw him on
set she was like that's the man that i'm
trying to be with if we were both single
and guess what they actually got caught
on a date
oh so yeah he took her up on the day
which i didn't think he was because he
looked uncomfortable he did look very
uncomfortable i didn't think that was
going to happen i didn't think so he's
got a great small that guy he's very
charming
i feel like he could do better you know
so you're not a fan of wendy williams i
mean
she's i don't know her really but i just
feel like looking at that guy i feel
like he can do better wait you don't
know her
you haven't heard of fart gate bro oh
she farted no
dude well so wendy williams has a
reputation
of farting farting on the show and she
keeps vehemently denying it
like like like you hear the farts or
she's smelly and people are like no like
it's so
loud her log bike is on her chest and it
picked up the audio oh my god like that
loud like there's this video clip of her
just moving aside and you just hear it
and then she just you could tell two
different sounds bro she she knew she
farted and she just starts continuing
this conversation
professional but everybody's like
clearly farted
and so but she does another episode
tonight she goes if i
farted i would have just opened up to it
like
[ __ ] she did an episode whole episode
about how she didn't fart
bro and clearly she farted she did it
twice
there was another episode where she
burped in the fart right after talk
she tried to try to cover it up what is
that [ __ ] and then she keeps denying
that she's farting on the show it's like
[ __ ] you farting this is a walking fast
you ever try to cover up your
fart with a cough no no let me tell you
something i sneezed and farted and
that's
pretty embarrassing i just fart and
we'll leave yo shout out shout out to
to [ __ ] this girl named me shawl in
high school
in the morning okay in the morning when
we had p.e and it's
obviously in the a.m right it's like 7
a.m in the [ __ ] morning dude farts
are just always funny dude
we would always start this wall dude
we would start we would [ __ ] start in
the morning
doing stretches right and i'm telling
you bro
doing stretches in the morning and this
[ __ ]
[ __ ] would not start be farting in the
morning dude
doing sit ups sitting on each one yo
that's my favorite thing ever
fiscal her name was michelle i'm only
gonna give her first name because how
embarrassing it was
michelle how many michelle are there
things yeah there's a lot of there's a
lot of
she's french she no she's she's indian
she's a little rotund indian girl
a little awkward right and so we're all
doing sit-ups in the morning
everybody's doing sit-ups it's in it's
in the [ __ ] basketball court the
gymnasium
it echoes the worst
it's 70 yen everybody's quiet it's
[ __ ] quiet
it's not the most mortifying thing ever
though as a kid yo like as a teenager
i'm talking about people girl oh my god
in front of your whole class dude
hilarious
i'm talking about somebody could
recorded that and sold it as adr
oh that's how perfect of a fart it was
and it should like that
dude she's like everybody is
busted up laughing and then the pe
teacher who's running it is like
everybody be quiet he had a southern
accent
everybody be quiet flatulence is
and he's crying laughing trying to
defend this girl
wow and he's making everybody laugh
because he's yelling at us but he's
laughing
at the same time it's true bro farts are
always funny they're always
you can't deny the [ __ ] letter
they're funny
i don't even try to hide him anymore i
don't even i don't even try to hide him
i know because you'd be reading books at
a coffee shop in the public like
he licks his fingers before he turns the
page
bro how did you why did we go there dude
because i saw him [ __ ] reading with a
monocle like [ __ ] he's mr monopoly guy
and he reads it up here like this
yeah it was a warm sunny day and
so
excuse me sir please stop narrating your
book dude i was so disappointed in this
dude man i'm like yeah could you read
them
[Music]
i feel like that's worse having the
screenplay out at a coffee shop is i
think worse than you know what the sad
thing is is because i'm
clearly doing like toxic masculinity
[ __ ] i want to read a book too in public
now i can't
i can't do it you can't because you
can't hurt a tree somewhere you can
you're just gonna feel like me you're
just gonna hope that you don't run into
anybody you know
and you're gonna kind of feel kind of
like a [ __ ] for a second and then
you're like oh you know
what were you reading i don't remember
now you remember i don't remember
i wanted to remember dude yeah yeah yeah
dr seuss broke green eggs and ham is
what i was saying how interesting yes
this example this is fantastic
they're spoiled but he continues to eat
them amazing turns into more of your
freeman i know salted ham
salted ham salt
they're in the bible dog jesus
[ __ ] oh
dude if you read the bible in public bro
dude i would [ __ ]
whatever wow that'd be aggressive what
if you're reading a book about dianetics
in public
that would be weird as [ __ ] that'd be
weird man i was reading the quran dude
the quran
that's okay i think that's fine quran
why yeah you think that's cool it was
just gonna be weird
i don't think i was reading this did you
guys see that [ __ ] footage
hey you know it's like the bible for
some people yeah but like get the guy
like have you ever seen a bible what do
you ever see a bible before
leather bound bro come on what's the wow
what kind of paper do they use for the
bible because that paper i've never
seen on any other it's straight from god
oh it could be just
the thinnest paper i've ever seen in my
life where does this paper where is this
paper produced in nature it's probably
so cheap
actually no it's not that's proven
feathers dude that's what it's made out
of proof that god is real
that's true because you don't see that
type of paper in anything else ever
do you think it's in the quran no i'm
sure the quran is very thick
too no i don't know i've never i've
never seen a quran ever in my life yeah
either oh maybe i should buy one just to
see what's up yeah i'm just going to buy
one just
have it i'm going to read it at the
coffee shop that you're reading yeah
yeah across me
yeah oh yeah you're reading a book watch
this it's a thick ass book this big
i'm gonna get the first quran ever show
that you're [ __ ] pissed
there dude but when he was so the funny
thing about wendy williams right there
was actually another scandal that
happened
big quran reader yeah she loves the
quran by the way so
years ago method man and her had beef
since like 2006 or something
right how random is that like that
method man
who's like this hard-ass rapper got a
beef with a shallow show host
wendy williams yeah so because so wendy
williams has a habit of [ __ ] opening
her mouth and saying [ __ ] that she
shouldn't stay
so with that type of [ __ ] and you know
at the time too i think she was
relatively new and she you know she's
trying to say all this inside scoop [ __ ]
to tell people this information so she
can get good ratings on her show
so she leaked out that method man's wife
had cancer
and method men did not want anybody to
know that her wife had cancer because he
started getting messages out of nowhere
like yo i heard about your wife having
cancer
and the one thing he asked his wife
asked of him was not to mention this to
anybody
because she didn't want to feel like
she's a charity case yeah so
everybody in their neighborhood found
out and they were like giving her
condolences and it was like her worst
nightmare ever
and so he's on this interview and met
the man is calling her a punk ass
[ __ ] like this [ __ ] [ __ ] he's like
cursing
he goes yeah [ __ ] wendy williams over
here telling my [ __ ] [ __ ] where
i'm from
you do that [ __ ] you get [ __ ] merc
you [ __ ] bitch-ass [ __ ]
yeah what if he killed wendy williams
over that dude i'd be kind of tight
so recently she was on a radio show
she was on a radio show and then she's
she said this rumor
that somebody asked her she was like oh
yeah so me and method like back in the
day
we were hooking up saying that he was
cheating on his [ __ ] wife who had
cancer but it's not true though right
no he's denying it and his wife's like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] no way that's good
he should be able to whoop her ass yeah
you should probably think legally he
should be able to because
dog how frustrating is that that's some
other lady
who you especially for him i'm sure is
like yo
i do not want to have sex with you bro
yeah for you to be publicly telling
people
while you're married that used to [ __ ]
and was cheating on your wife bro when
she had cancer
dog and you're fighting do you want to
fight fighting you i don't care if
you're a girl if you do that [ __ ] i'm
gonna fight you
that's legal that should be a legal
aspect because you know why because
wifey at home is
in that ass she's like she's making your
life hell
excuse over some [ __ ] you know what
i mean
and it's just crazy yeah yeah it's just
that it hurts his [ __ ] white he has
to see his wife be like upset about this
[ __ ]
no of course what the [ __ ] it's really
bad on all sides
it's just a really weird situation i'm
like what's what what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you ladies that's cool yeah what a
crazy [ __ ] she looks like [ __ ] why did
gary go out with this [ __ ]
she's gross as [ __ ] i think his like
standing for women is like they just got
to be [ __ ] black american
you think he just did that for optics
maybe because it is like oh yeah okay we
can go out for a day but maybe
i'm not really feeling it maybe to piss
off his uh ex-wife oh
but it's like with wendy williams
you got against [ __ ] kermit the frog
you don't like wendy williams
she looks like the frog and miss piggy
at the same time yeah is she the lady
that like passed out on tv one time yes
that is her she actually has great she
has great
[ __ ] her ph levels dropped she's fun
c3 vertebrae went out dude but i don't
know where she was like
you farted
and now i'm being made fun of whatever
dude [ __ ] it and that's this guy bro
don't tell this guy [ __ ] anything hey
man you made fun of me for reading the
coffee shop
you've been drinking for education for
crying for brandon moreno dude
adorable it's a little [ __ ] soft
though am i right guys i mean [ __ ] that
dude she actually has graves disease
what the [ __ ] is that it's a scientific
graves disease it's like a thyroid issue
so either you have to
fix it through surgery or medication or
something like that
but that's the reason why she has big
old [ __ ] eyes that bulge out one of
the side effects
possible side effects of having grace
disease is disease disease
is when your eyes pop out so she always
looks like she's surprised all the time
she looks like a pug do this damn bro
she's a little bit of surgery though
right because they're always kind of
crazy
tiff showed me a picture of uh one of
the jenners
the uh kardashian ones the one that got
a bunch of plastic kim kardashian
caitlyn jenner caitlyn jenner kylie
jenner kylie is she the one married to
travis scott
that's the one yeah yeah she showed me a
picture of her face
crazy dog it got even worse like she's
doing more plastic surgery it looks like
it looks like a mask on top of her
regular face it's an addiction
it's a straight addiction oh no more
alcohol it's an addiction though yeah
like once you
here here's the thing like we've talked
about plastic surgery on this podcast
before and the consistent
argument for plastic surgery is it's my
body i have a limited time on this earth
why can't i do it what i want it's
nobody gives a [ __ ] what you really do
with your face yeah it's just
it's just a topic of like once you get
something done
it's non-stop you're trying to prevent
something that you cannot prevent
it [ __ ] with you psychologically yeah
we have not seen it
the other way around yeah because once
you accept it and you understand
what's happening then you'd be like okay
cool it's natural i'm part
you know you could feel some type of way
about getting older having wrinkles and
stuff like you're going to get old
right and this idea and of like wanting
to always be [ __ ] why yeah who the
[ __ ] cares you're getting old
well it's just it's just it shows how
blatantly like insecure you are
it's like really you went to that length
to cover this up recovery you can just
accept who the [ __ ] you are yeah like
really
because you heard the [ __ ] out of here
you heard about the uh the chloe
kardashian thing right
where she somebody leaked a picture of
her in a bikini
and she it was oh yeah oh that's right
optimal it wasn't perfect
this is not how i really did it and then
she went on instagram was like this is
what i really look like and it's a bunch
of videos and like
it's like bro the picture that got
leaked
wasn't that bad like you don't look like
a terrible
like she looked fine and also gives a
[ __ ] exactly and especially too she's
like
you know all these people are holding me
to an unfair beauty standard yadda yadda
yadda and it's like
dawg the kardashians might be the most
influential like family
in modern-day how people
look the plastic surgery right you go to
west hollywood or anywhere in that
like like we went to the century city
mall all the girls that are there
they look exactly like that how crazy is
that like the big
lips like the but that's the look at the
hypocrisy in that statement she goes
you guys hold me to an unfair beauty
standard you're the one who got plastic
surgery
you you are the blueprint yeah so what
are you talking about you set the
standard
yeah you set the standard and then she
wants to act like i'm sure
she trains i'm sure she does all the
fitness stuff i'm sure
but for her to get all these body
implants and then claim that she's like
natural is like mom bro stop like what
don't do that to yourself yeah that's
[ __ ] because people would [ __ ] with
you even harder if you were just like
look yeah
i got some blood implants i got some you
know i guess if you want to do all that
stuff that
and it makes you happy i'm not here to
tell you what to do with your life i
personally don't give a [ __ ] right
but i i maybe it's because i live in
this city and i see it happen so much
and i've known people
they're not my friends but i've known
them and i've seen them consistently
whenever we see each other they're
getting new things done they still
complain about their face
they still complain that something is
sagging and every time they look weirder
and weirder and weirder because exactly
they're trying to hold on to something
that's fleeting
you are going to get old yeah that's a
fact that's just what it is
yeah and you're focusing on stuff that
doesn't even develop yourself as a human
being
i'm not talking about people who have
like certain cosmetic issues like they
were born with like a weird nose that's
exactly what you're talking about
off camera that's the day yeah yeah
exactly i was not
you a calf cramping [ __ ] wendy williams
you bro i just started some [ __ ] that's
how it starts bro oh really
fart gate
[Laughter]
[Music]
this guy's complaining about how graves
is whatever gray's disease is this guy
don't know
i don't know nothing about graves
disease because he's too busy crying to
[ __ ] hear people out how about that
well guys you could catch dick the ear
at nick the [ __ ] ear that's
nick the ear dot com instagram nick the
ear
uh you have a [ __ ] that's a good like
uh
introduction that's right bang patrick.
that's right
i'll carry on now okay
that's the catchphrase for jesus rant
good morning y'all oh god i live in
baton rouge louisiana i just made gumbo
all day
uh patrick.tdot riley on error thing you
can see him on the comedy clubs on the
circuit making people ha ha ha giggle
giggle
thursdays and sundays geniusbrain every
time see y'all next time